CHARLES FRIED: Well, you've probably already worked this all out,
but let me help you with a couple of stories.
One of them is a story of Jonah and the whale.
Remember what happens with Jonah?
Jonah is on the ship, and they have a tremendous storm.
And they figure out one of the things we have to do is throw Jonah overboard.
And that'll calm the waters, because the good Lord is angry with Jonah.
You know the rest of the story.
But that story connects up to the ancient law of the sea, which
even today is respected.
The ancient law of the sea addresses this problem.
You've got a storm at sea.
You have a cargo, which is in peril, and the master of the ship
reasonably decides that in order to survive-- in order for the sailors,
and for the passengers, and for any of the cargo to survive,
they've got to throw a significant part of the cargo overboard.
They've got to lighten the ship.
And that's what they do.
The ship survives, they put into port, and they unload the remaining cargo.
Well, what about those people whose cargo
was thrown overboard to save the ship?
Are they just out of luck?
Maybe some of them had very heavy cargo, and so that's
why the master quite reasonably decided to throw it overboard.
And the others had lighter but much more valuable
cargo-- let's say silk or spices-- and that's what survived.
Could we just say that the folks whose stuff was thrown overboard
are out of luck, and the others are in luck?
That's not what the ancient law of the seas says,
and that's not the law of the sea now.
Today, you have a rule which goes by the name of general average.
And the general average is what you do in a situation like this.
You figure out what the total value of the cargo of the ship was.
Let's say the total value was worth $1,000.
What you did is you had to throw $300 worth of cargo overboard--
$300 worth of stone or blocks of marble--
to save the remaining cargo of silk and spices.
The remaining cargo doesn't just thank its lucky stars and count its blessings
all the way to the bank.
Not at all.
We saw 3/10 of the worth of the total cargo was lost.
It was sacrificed in order to save the remaining cargo.
The marble was sacrificed in order to save the silk and spices.
Under the law of the sea, the owners of all the cargo
get together under what's called general average and each of them
ends up with 7/10 of the value of the total cargo.
The people whose cargo was thrown overboard
get 7/10 of the value of theirs.
And the people whose cargo survived get only 7/10 of theirs.
It's a kind of insurance policy, a sharing of risk.
They all shared the risk, and they all ended up losing proportionately.
But nobody lost everything.
Nobody got away without losing something-- well, except for Jonah.